this is Gulfstream g650 the biggest
fastest and most expensive private jet
in the world you won't get much change
out of 65 million dollars for this one
over there you can see one of the
rolls-royce BR seven-25 engines as two
of them on this jet helping propel it to
a top speed of 610 miles per hour but as
with so many things in life it's not
just what's on the outside that's
important but it's what's inside that
counts to the force first things first
we've got the cockpit and the pilot Eric
over there what probably looks like a
giant Google glass type display in fact
that's among the most advanced
instruments you can find in avionics
helping the pilot to see even when
visibility is dramatically reduced but
of course totally back here which is
what you really want to see the luxury
that can only be found on a private jet
so if you come this way this is where
your average billionaire or plutocrat
owner of the g650 is going to sit as
you'd expect you're surrounded by luxury
you can smell the leather there's wood
everywhere it's all made to order so you
get whichever lever and whichever wood
you actually want as you'd expect there
are a few toys here if I press this
button then out pops my table
automatically saving me the terrible
strain and possible injury of having to
do it manually these windows you see
here they're the biggest that you'll
find on any private jet and I'm told
that when the g650 is in the air it's
quieter than any other business jet out
the back there you've got a stateroom
for a bit of privacy or to hold a
business meeting perhaps to have a
lie-down and there is just one more toy
I want to show you and that's this if I
turn on this iPod Touch that comes with
the plane press this button my blinds
come down automatically as well now
Gulfstream has taken two hundred orders
of the g650 since its launch nearly a
year ago but if you want to get hold of
one now and you place your order right
now you won't see it until 2017